In the calculus
playlist, we came up
with a rationale
for Euler's formula.
And I guess that video has
gotten somewhat famous with me
talking about minds being blown
and people not having emotion.
But just as a reminder,
Euler's formula
is that e to the i theta--
Just the formula by
itself is pretty amazing,
but it becomes
especially amazing
when you substitute
pi or tau for theta.
And if you don't know what tau
is, there are videos on that.
But Euler's formula tells
us that e to the i theta--
there's a very good rationale
for saying that this is going
to be equal to cosine
of theta plus--
and I'll just change the color
for fun-- plus i sine of theta.
And so one thing I want to do
is explore this a little bit.
Can I express-- because
of Euler's formula-- can
I now express cosine
of theta in terms
of some combination
of the other stuff?
And can I now
express sine of theta
in terms of some other
combination of the other stuff?
Well, let's think about how
we can isolate a cosine theta.
If this is e to
the i theta, let's
see what e to the
negative i theta would be.
Actually, let me do it over
here on the right-hand side.
So e to the negative i theta.
This is the same thing
as e to the i times
negative theta, which--
by Euler's formula--
it would be equal to cosine
of negative theta plus i
sine of negative theta.
Well, cosine of
negative theta-- this
is the same thing
as cosine of theta.
And sine of negative
theta is the same thing
as negative sine of theta.
So this whole thing simplifies
to negative i sine of theta.
So we can write e to
the negative i theta.
Let me do that pink color.
We can write e to
the negative i theta
as being equal to cosine of
theta minus i sine of theta.
And now we have something
pretty interesting going on.
If we add these two expressions,
these two equalities
right over here,
the left-hand side--
so let's just add them up.
The left-hand side,
we're going to be
left with e to the i theta
plus e to the negative i theta.
And on the right-hand
side, these i
sine thetas are going to
cancel out with each other.
And we're going to be left
with 2 times cosine of theta.
And so now it's pretty
straightforward.
I just isolate the cosine
theta, divide both sides by 2.
Divide both sides
by 2, and we get
something pretty interesting.
We get that cosine of theta
is equal to this business-- e
to the i theta plus e to
the negative i theta, all
of that over 2.
And we could do a
similar type of thing
to try to isolate--
let me rewrite it over.
So let me rewrite this
little discovery we made.
Cosine of theta can be
rewritten as e to the i theta
plus e to the negative i
theta all of that over 2.
So that's kind of interesting.
We can now express
cosine of theta
in terms of a bunch of
exponentials right over here.
Let's see if we could do the
same thing for sine of theta.
Let's imagine e to the i
theta-- and let's try to do it
the other way.
There's always these
weird kind of parallels
between cosine and sine.
So let's just see
what happens if we
were to subtract this from that.
So let's try doing that.
If we were to take
e to the i theta--
let me just rewrite it over
again. e to the i theta
is equal to cosine of
theta plus i sine of theta.
And from that, let's subtract
e to the negative i theta.
Well, now we're going
to subtract this.
So we're going to get
negative cosine theta.
And then, we're
subtracting this.
So plus i sine theta.
And so we are left with--
when we do the subtraction--
the left-hand side, we
have e to the i theta
minus e to the negative i
theta is equal to-- this
cancels out-- and we're left
with 2i times sine theta.
If we want to solve
for sine theta,
we divide both sides by 2i.
And we are going to be
left with sine theta is
equal to this business
right over here.
So let's do this.
So this is our other
discovery-- sine theta
can be written as
e to the i theta
minus e to the negative i
theta, all of that over 2i.
So there's something interesting
about these structures.
I can write cosine of theta
is the sum of these two
exponentials that are dealing
with imaginary numbers, sine
of theta as the difference of
these two exponential numbers
dealing with imaginary numbers.
Actually, over
here, it's actually
the average of
the two functions.
You're dividing by 2.
Here we're dividing by 2i.
And if you don't like
that i in the denominator,
you can multiply the numerator
and the denominator by i.
This will become a negative.
You'll have the i
in the numerator.
But either way, you will
have the same expression.
So this is all I
can say about this.
This is just kind
of interesting.
It's just kind of a fun
exploration of mathematics.
But maybe there's something
neat about the structure
of these functions.
What happens if we were to
take functions like this,
but if we were to essentially
get rid of the i's right
over here?
They seem like there
might be some kind
of an analog between cosine
of theta and sine of theta.
And so let's define
those functions.
And in the next
few videos, we'll
explore them and
see if they really
are analogous in some bizarre,
strange, and beautiful way
to cosine of theta
and sine theta.
So we're just going to make
new function definitions,
and they're just being
inspired by these new ways
that we discovered to write
cosine of theta and sine theta.
And I'm going to call
the first function cosh.
And it really does come
from hyperbolic cosine,
and we'll explore more why
we call it hyperbolic cosine.
But let's just call it cosh.
I'm just experimenting
right over here.
And we'll just say cosh of x
is equal to-- it's going to be
inspired by this, but we're
going to get rid of all
of the i's.
So it's going to
be e to the x plus
e to the negative x,
all of that over 2.
Once again, just inspired
by this right over here.
Getting rid of all of the i's.
And then, let's define
another one-- hyperbolic sine.
So I'll call it sinh.
Sinh for hyperbolic sine.
Sinh-- I guess you
could also do-- of x.
And I'm just to get
rid of all of the i's.
I'm just being inspired by this.
So e to the x minus e to the
negative x, all of that over 2.
And in the next
few videos, we're
going to start exploring this.
And we're going
to start realizing
that there is this
strange, bizarre parallel
between these things and our
traditional trigonometric
functions.
Now, these will show up in
some of your mathematics,
but it is important.
These aren't as
core-- especially
in traditional mathematics-- as
these two characters are here,
but it is a fun exploration.